was it Han Solo what it Greedo it's the
age-old question but if jokes on Twitter
or anything to go by we know it was
actually Chris Miller who shot first I'm
Simon and this is your intergalactic
news update we may not know who is to
play the young han Solo in the
forthcoming Star Wars spin-off movie but
we do now have the first official image
to celebrate star wars day yesterday
co-director Chris Miller tweeted a
picture of the space smugglers famous
blaster Miller is to direct with Phil
Lord from a script by Star Wars veteran
Lawrence Kasdan and his son John Miller
and Lords previous work includes the
Jump Street films and the lego movie the
question of who will play the young han
Solo is one the fans have been
speculating on for months in April it
was reported that Alden Ehrenreich was
currently the frontrunner for the part
while other actors who have tested for
the role include Jack reynor taron
egerton and dave Franco in a recent
interview for MTV News Franco spoke
about his experience of auditioning for
the role and explained why producers
were taking their time deciding who
should portray solo I'm not good with
impressions and I think that's the
reason it's so hard to cause this role
do they want to like perfectly embody
who Harrison Ford is or do they want to
go a completely different route do they
want someone to look really similar to
him I think they're struggling with that
the han solo film is currently set for a
release on May twenty-fifth 2018 who do
you think should play everyone's
favorite space smuggler let me know in
the comments or come find me on Twitter
i'm at the Jagan or thanks for watching
and for all your entertainment news keep
it gamespot